so why did a surprise guest come to chit-chat?
And who's the real hero in this movie?
If you saw the 2019 film "Shazam" then
you may recall the scene in which Billy
Batson is first transported to the Rock
of Eternity to meet the wizard Shazam.
"My name is Shazam."
"Wait, for real?"
As Billy tries to make sense of what's going
on, Shazam explains that he is the last of the
council of wizards and he is looking for
someone pure of heart to pass his powers
onto in order to protect humanity from the
seven deadly sins. The reason he has to be
so picky is because the last time the power
was passed to someone ... it didn't go so well.
We learn a bit more about that in this
film, because Black Adam, or Teth-Adam as
he's originally called, is the reason Shazam
has to be careful about who gets the powers.
Bestowed with the stamina of Shu, the
speed of Horus, the strength of Amon,
the wisdom of Zehuti, the Powers of Aten and the
courage of Mehen, Adam used his incredible powers
to seek revenge on the ruler of Kahndaq instead
of being the hero the seven wizards intended.
The story of "Black Adam" is about the character
gradually getting to a place mentally where he can
embody some of the attributes the wizards were
looking for. However, since he was not the one
they initially chose to wield the power,
he will never become a traditional hero.
5,000 years after Teth Adam brought down Anh-Kot,
a woman named Adrianna Tomaz releases him from his
prison by speaking the words engraved on the
seal trapping him in some kind of limbo state.
The second he shows up, Adam goes on a
lightning-spitting rampage as he kills
the soldiers coming at him with guns and
tanks, and all sorts of useless weapons.
Since the legends say that Teth Adam
would return when Kahndaq needs him most,
everyone naturally assumes that this
super-strong guy who looks like the
statue they built thousands of years ago
is there to rescue them from Intergang.
Unfortunately, they couldn't be more wrong. The
only reason Adam has killed those men is because
they were in his way and they were attacking
him — he has no intention of saving anyone.
This doesn't fit with all the legends they've
heard, and there's a good reason for that:
this isn't the Teth-Adam the wizards initially
chose to have their powers. They selected the
boy Hurut, who was the son of the man
currently carrying the name Teth-Adam.
Hurut gave his powers to his father to
protect him, but was assassinated shortly
after. Therefore, the man flying around
modern-day Kahndaq is a broken father
who's lost the only thing he's ever loved,
and who sees his own existence as a curse.
The Justice Society of America is called
in to take Adam into custody because he
poses a threat to the safety of the
United States and every other country
in the world if he were to suddenly
decide he'd like to rule the world.
Black Adam's rage and thirst for vengeance
released the seven deadly sins upon the world,
resulting in six of the seven wizards
getting obliterated and entire
civilizations being wiped out.
Despite being the "good guys," the
Justice Society has inherited Amanda
Waller's sanctimonious attitude when it
comes to what heroes can and cannot do.
Aside from continuously lecturing
Adam on proper heroic etiquette,
they also just assume that the people of
Kahndaq are going to step aside for the
Justice Society. Why? Because they're the ones
with the superpowers, therefore they know best.
"You think yourself a hero but you
would let these criminals go free."
"Heroes don’t kill people."
However, this is a country that has been invaded
and occupied for years, and not once did the
Justice Society come to help. Only after the JSA
can learn to work with Adam and the citizens of
Kahndaq are they able to get any work done. We see
that at the end, when instead of charging in and
destroying things, Atom Smasher and Cyclone use
their powers to work in tandem with the people.
When "Black Adam" opens, we're given a very
detailed breakdown of everything that went
down in Kahndaq in the year 2600 BC, thanks
to a voiceover from the character Amon Tomaz.
He tells us all about how a magical element
called Eternium can be found in Kahndaq,
and that an ancient ruler had his slaves dig for
the element in order to forge the Crown of Sabbac
so he could wield ultimate power. However, Black
Adam took the crown and destroyed his empire.
In this prologue, we see Hurut with an
old man, but once we get the full story,
we realize that the old man was actually the boy's
father, and he looks remarkably like Black Adam.
While a tad confusing at first, this actually
demonstrates just how much of Kahndaq's past
and resources had been co-opted by
outside forces over the centuries.
When the Justice Society explains they've had
access to ancient texts that say Black Adam was
a destroyer instead of a hero, Amon's
mother Adrianna doesn't believe them.
It is very likely that people have been
coming to Kahndaq and stealing from it
so much, that even its own history is incomplete.
Therefore, when we see Amon's story, what
we're seeing is his interpretation of events,
not the events as they actually unfolded.
This stands as yet another reason why
Kahndaq needs a protector:
to keep their history intact.
"I kneel before no one."
When the truth comes out that Black
Adam isn't the hero of legend,
he agrees to go with the JSA to be locked up
forever. He doesn't want these powers anymore,
since he never felt worthy of them to begin with.
He makes the JSA promise that after he says
"Shazam" and transforms back to his original form,
they will never allow him to speak the
word again. He is tired of carrying this
burden and welcomes the idea of being free
of it, even if that means being locked up.
They take him to an underwater Task Force X
prison run by Amanda Waller. She, of course,
is the director of A.R.G.U.S, an agency that
engages in numerous clandestine missions across
the globe to make sure superhumans do not
threaten the security of the United States.
Task Force X is a division of A.R.G.U.S.
where imprisoned villains in the DC Universe
are used to carry out many of those
missions in exchange for time off of
their sentences. You might remember
them better as The Suicide Squad.
"Well, we consider that term degrading.
The official term is Task Force X."
When the members of the JSA arrive,
they're greeted by Emilia Harcourt.
Fans of the HBO series "Peacemaker"
will likely remember her as an NSA
agent working for Waller in that series
and in the film "The Suicide Squad."
She points out that the Gods were meant to be
humanity's heroes, but humanity seems to be the
one always burying them. All of this suggests that
Task Force X is powerful enough to control Adam.
"Funny for you how often the only
choice in killing people coincides."
Doctor Fate is a man with a thousand storm
clouds swirling over his head at all times,
as the sentient Alien Helmet of Nabu he wears
reveals every possible version of the future.
He knows that the future is unwritten, but
due to circumstances out of his control,
he can't always predict which series of
events will unfold. His job is to step
in and make sure that the decisions made by
the JSA result in the best possible outcome.
Throughout much of the film, he is dreading
the completion of the mission because he
knows the version of events where they save
the day requires his friend Hawkman to die.
"Nothing but heartache."
When Sabbac rises from the underworld
to conquer Earth, Fate knows the "happy"
ending is approaching, but he's not about to let
Hawkman go. He steps in and sacrifices himself.
While doing so, he uses his power to
be in two places at once to free Adam,
because he knows Adam is the only
one powerful enough to defeat Sabbac.
He tells Adam that he should accept his abilities
because "Fate doesn't make mistakes," and at that
moment Doctor Fate has literally chosen Adam
to save humanity — whether he wants it or not.
Fate's sacrifice also allows
Hawkman to hold the helmet in
order to multiply himself and distract
Sabbac, turning the tide of the battle.
Despite his many faults, the
antagonist of the film isn’t
actually Black Adam. It’s a man named Ishmael.
At first, he appears to be working with Adrianna
to help free Kahndaq, but he's actually looking
for the Crown of Sabbac. No one really knows
why he wants it, so they check the engraving
within it, only to find that it reads that life
is the only road to death, which seems obvious.
What they don't know is that the power
from the crown comes from the underworld,
which serves as a dark reflection of our world.
This means the inscription is really telling
them that death is the only road to life.
Ishmael wants the crown because he
is the descendent of King Anh-Kot,
and only his bloodline can wear
the crown and use its power.
When Ishmael gets the crown, he is
killed and sent to the underworld,
where six demons grant him the
evil version of Black Adam's power,
and he rises from that realm to command
an undead army to conquer the world.
Black Adam is the only one who can stop
him. After briefly visiting the afterlife,
where his son tells him it isn't his time yet,
Adam returns to Kahndaq and battles Sabbac.
While he handles that, ordinary citizens fight his
skeleton army. Finally, Adam rips Sabbac in half,
destroying the crown and Sabbac's power,
at last freeing Kahndaq — for now, that is.
"We’ll take care of the rest."
As the dust begins to settle and everyone
realizes the battle has been won,
the question posed to Adam is whether or
not he is willing to be Kahndaq's hero.
He destroys the throne meant for their
savior because it feels wrong. Even after
5,000 years of imprisonment, Adam knows that
Kahndaq doesn't need a ruler — it needs people
who are willing to work together
to return it to its former glory.
"Kahndaq already has heroes," he says, having met
people like Adrianna and her son Amon who believe
in Kahndaq and want to see it thrive again. Their
hearts and intentions are pure, unlike his own.
This goes back to the start of the
film, when Hurut stresses the need
for everyone to stand up and fight their
enslavers when everyone else is too scared.
Adrianna and Amon are this generation's version of
Hurut. With Intergang gone and Sabbac killed, they
can organize the citizens to work together. While
that's going on, Kahndaq still needs a protector,
someone who can stand in the way when an invading
force shows up looking to occupy them again.
That is the role Adam is more comfortable with,
because he still isn't one for rescuing people.
He will not save Kahndaq, but he will punish and
destroy anyone who thinks they can invade it.
This is a sign that he is moving away from being
a total anti-hero and compromising a little bit.
Adam is released from his prison and
enters a world already flush with
super-powered beings capable of incredible feats.
By the end of the film, Adam has been reborn:
his suit is more vibrant, he's been encouraged
by the spirit of his son to do more, and
he even changes his name to Black Adam.
Thus, he is more reminiscent of the
character we know from the comics:
a character capable of doing good, but
with dubious morals and the potential
to go from good to evil depending
on the situation. This is, perhaps,
why Amanda Waller isn't very happy about
him not remaining in her underwater prison.
Once the end credit sequence comes to a close,
we fade up to see a drone descending from
the sky before Black Adam. A hologram of
Amanda Waller projects from the device
and she, as usual, doesn't look happy.
She tells him that since he won't be staying in
her prison, he is required to remain in Kahndaq.
If he steps beyond its borders, she'll make
sure it's the last thing he ever does. Since
he isn't fond of serving a master, Adam
tells her no one on Earth can stop him.
She threatens to "call in a favor" with
beings from other planets. He tells her
to send them all. The hologram ends and
we see Superman emerge from the shadows.
He tells Adam that it's been a while since anyone
has frightened the people of Earth quite as much
as he has, suggesting that Black Adam's presence
is akin to the arrival of Superman himself.
Although he says he just wants to talk, Black
Adam's penchant for foregoing discussion in
favor of violence pretty much guarantees
their conversation will not go well. Perhaps
that means the sequel could feature a
fight between Black Adam and Superman.
Hopefully, a potential "Black
Adam 2" can also explain why
Superman would do favors for someone like Waller,
given her shady tactics. Perhaps she didn't
send him and he really did just come to talk.